it's the first weekend of April 2019 so
it's time for another monthly update
video in which I'm going to talk about
what we've got going on during this
month and what you might have missed
during the month of March I always like
to begin by highlighting three big
things big thing number one is left over
from last month that we didn't get to a
video premiere how to engage in
self-study of Plato big thing number two
we have our first meeting of the year
for the Sofia chapter here in Milwaukee
Sofia is the larger national
organization Society of philosophers in
America and big thing number three I
actually got a paper proposal accepted
for a conference that's going to be here
in June the Aristotle and the
Aristotelian tradition conference so
I'll talk a little bit about that in the
April section and yeah that's quite an
honor it's a very selective conference
they get a lot of proposals and mine is
going through March was a long month
which meant that in theory I should have
been able to get a lot of things done
but it was also a difficult month in
part because both my wife and I were
sick with a strain of the flu that
really puts people out for weeks and
weeks and weeks and I actually had to
take some time off my my spring break at
two of the places I was teaching was
almost entirely consumed with being in
bed or getting in just a little bit of
work each day I didn't get to exercise
during pretty much the entire month so
the first really half of the month after
the first few days it was pretty rough
and I still continued teaching you know
I did take a few days off from classes
but for the most part I soldiered on and
went in and taught my classes and then
I'd be totally exhausted after
towards so I didn't I didn't get as much
done and I actually had to cancel one of
my face-to-face events on Mary Shelley's
novels including Frankenstein in The
Last Man which hopefully we're going to
reschedule and I also had to reschedule
the the play-doh video premiere because
I didn't get to shooting that video in
March what I did do I managed to get in
a talk on Epictetus slavery stoicism in
the Roman Empire early on in the month
so that's good that's part of the
philosophers in the midst of history I
did also hold a 500 core concept videos
online celebration we have a video from
that I held my AMA and did my philosophy
pop up so you can see those videos as
well am I did a talk here locally for a
group of seniors about Aristotle
friendship and romantic relationships
lots of teaching you know as I think
many of you know I'm teaching more than
full time this semester five classes at
three different institutions which keeps
me pretty busy I also carried on some
philosophical counseling work and did
some consulting work and of course I
have my tutorial students so I had quite
a full plate and you know I'm editor of
Stoicism today and we're you know not
only do we have the normal work for that
but I'm also working on a proposal for
some edited volumes coming out of that
and there's all of the gearing up for
stoical on stomach on axes stoic weak
which happens later in the fall but the
planning happens now so I've been kept
pretty busy with with all of that my
kids also came to visit for their Spring
Break and you know when they're here in
the summer I can I can get some work
done but I've pretty much given up on
getting any real work done other than
having to go to classes while they're
here for these many vacations we had a
good time you know we did some fun thing
made some some good dishes and and
played some games together and and you
know had a lot of great talks and that
sort of thing and they actually my son
came to my Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design class and my daughter came to
my intro philosophy class so that was
kind of nice what else I did some video
work as you know the Epictetus video is
out there I also shot a video or not
really shot at per se but rather put it
together of memes that people have
featured my image in and that got a good
bit of traction I'll put a link to that
below you know the other online events
we had you know videos of those which
you can see I shot some core concept
videos mostly on unda carts meditations
I got quite a few of those done and then
ran out of steam as I got sick I didn't
get any half-hour hagel videos done this
month I am for those who are asking
about this I am still continuing with
the project it's just that Hegel videos
are quite demanding to to do for me and
when I'm sick I don't have the presence
of mind to do that when my kids are here
the presence of mind either so that's
what went on during March what's coming
up in April we have quite a packed
schedule on the 9th at 5 p.m. I'll be
having my first online event of the
month and that is the Hegel Q&A and
discussion session for the general
public
anybody can drop into that video
conferencing session if they wish to of
course this is Central Time so make sure
that you check your time zone 11 on the
11th that's 7 p.m. here locally at the
Brookfield Public Library I will be
continuing with the worlds of
speculative fiction series with a talk
Lewis Carroll's fantastic worlds
obviously we're going to talk quite a
bit about the Alice books but also his
biography and backstory the fact that he
was a Dean
logic and and we'll be talking about his
books on logic and also his interest in
photography and some some other topics
as well on the 13th at 12 p.m. Central
Time I will be finally getting to that
video premiere on how to study Plato on
your own I'll be giving a lot of tips a
lot of important suggestions some links
to resources and you know I'll take
questions and answers while we're doing
the video premiere so it's a chance for
you to see the video for the first time
a link will be provided to that but not
right now because I haven't yet shot the
video so before you ask a question in
the comment where's the link to that
it'll be there and then I'll post it in
all my social media so if you're
following me you'll be able to access it
quite quite easily on the 13th as well
at 2:00 p.m. we will have our patreon
exclusive Haegele Q&A session that's
where the patreon supporters of the
half-hour hagel project on the 20th at
12 p.m. I will have my monthly AMA
session I've actually blocked out an
hour and a half because these always
tend to run over and so if you've got
questions for me that's the time to ask
them make sure you get your questions in
early because we always have more
questions at the end than can be
answered also on the 20th 3 p.m.
another patreon perk philosophy chat for
my patreon supporters that that's one of
the perks that they enjoy another video
conferencing session with me then again
locally on the 23rd at 6 p.m. Shorewood
Public Library we have the MK e that's
Milwaukee stoic fellowship we are
finishing up with epictetus discourses
and discussing where we want to go next
and then finally on the 30th the very
last day of the month at 6 p.m. we
have our Sofia chapter meeting that's
our first Sofia event of the year Sofia
is the Society of philosophers in
America it is an organization devoted to
doing public philosophy so that is going
to be quite a fun event we're gonna
discuss you know the nature of public
philosophy civil discourse and start
setting out some of the things we want
to do over the course of the year and we
really want to do some building of that
organization here in the Milwaukee area
in part because there's not a lot that's
that's meeting people's needs in that
way here in Milwaukee and we want to
create more opportunities for people to
study and engage with and talk about
philosophy with each other I'm also
still of course teaching my classes my
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
and my Marquette classes are more or
less winding down over this month they
they go a little bit into the month of
May but for the most part they're
they're ending all the real content is
ending in April
the Milwaukee Area Technical College
classes go well into May so that's you
know not going to be wrapping up but
they started late too as well but I'm
starting to work on the online classes
that I'm going to be teaching this
summer for Milwaukee Institute of Art
Design I'm teaching a six-week
existentialism class and for Marquette
University I'm teaching a six-week
business ethics class so I'm getting all
that sort of stuff ready you know to
roll because as soon as the students
open up the class everything needs to be
in there including the lecture videos
any podcast that I want to do links
interviews all that that content still
you know doing philosophical counseling
consulting tutorial work lots of
editorial work this month of doing a lot
of writing as well a lot of it for
classes but also at medium some stuff
and stoicism today some stuff in my
author blog or xst an erotic a probably
be answering some Korra questions as
well and perhaps even doing some writing
in other places videos I'm gonna be of
course recording my event videos both
the face-to-face and online ones I've
got a lot of core concept videos I need
to still shoot out des cartes
meditations I don't think I'm going to
get to Humes inquiry unfortunately but
because now I need to actually start
shooting videos that I'm going to use as
my existentialism class so that means
some more videos on Friedrich Nietzsche
some videos on Dostoevsky mostly on the
underground man perhaps on on some parts
of Brothers Karamazov or maybe some
other things as well and then some core
concept videos also on Martin Buber if I
get to it
Rainer Maria Rilke and some other
thinkers that I need to really get
cracking on so we'll see what I'm able
to generate for those want to get back
to shooting my half-hour Hegel videos
that's a real priority for the month
don't know whether I'll get the six that
I used to get in before I started
teaching so much in but but we'll see it
I'll definitely get some done and it
won't be another month you know of no
videos and I need to start shooting some
book review videos as well we'll see
what I can shoot on top of that it's
going to be a pretty packed month from
this point onward it's probably going to
be a video release per day just to stay
on top of all of this and that means I'm
have to shoot you know more than a video
per day in order for that to happen
since I've once again you know patreon
support kind of fell in it now it's back
up to the level where I'd committed to
doing the Sadler's lectures podcast I'm
going to start putting out Sandler's
lectures podcast episodes again so you
can look forward to hearing those rather
than seeing those of course and we're
going to keep on cranking away at it
like
I've gots a lot of projects underway I
will mention I am going down to see my
kids both of them are in a production of
Fiddler on the Roof that happens about
mid-month
but other than that I'm staying right
here in Milwaukee and just seeing these
classes to their end and cranking out
content and gearing up for the summer
and trying to get as much work done as
possible during this month and going
back to the gym I you know now that I my
kids are gone and I'm healthy I went
back hadn't been there for at least a
month took me about three days not to be
a completely sore but we're going back
you know today I'll be going hopefully
to the to the to the wack and and the
Wisconsin Athletic Club and doing some
some exercise and then I'll start to
make it a regular thing 49 if 48 year
old body doesn't recover from exercise
the way a 28 year old body or 18 year
old body does but it's very important to
do so there's my month ahead and month
behind hope all of you have a great
month and hopefully I'll see some of you
either in the face-to-face or online
events
you